but you have to realize that it's first
it's not enough
and and you have to be very much
conscious of
not getting in love too much with your
idea especially with your solution
[Music]
thank you so much for joining me on 20
minute leaders how are you
doing how are you thank you so much for
having me
thank you very much for for spending
time here and i know how busy you are
and making a lot of impact and that's
what i want to talk about today
impact the impact that you're making
right now
is in the context of 8200 impact
and i can't wait to hear all about that
but but your journey is just as
fascinating as the work that you're
doing now and i know that you want to
focus
a lot on on the on the impact of this
organization but but i have to ask you a
little bit about yourself
and a little bit about your upbringing
start all the way back from when you're
leading
the chorus group in your elementary
school and then zip forward all the way
to
uh to your public work moving to the
private sector go ahead
yeah that's a really nice fun fact right
um so besides inside singing and it was
only until uh elementary school
uh you know when my voice changed then
uh my plans
have changed too but i've always wanted
to be
socially involved and and to lead social
activism wherever i was so
even you know studying in high school
when i was the head of this
student council then through um
initiating all these special projects
during my military service at 8 200
units
and and through my university uh
experience when i went to law school
uh in haifa university i was the head of
the students um
both there um it was always about
using my skills knowledge passion right
to make things happen and change
you know whatever there is to change and
fix
um so this is basically who i am so
whenever
i need to choose my um next step in my
career path
i'm always looking at the intersection
of what i
know to do and what i desire to do and i
hope to find
you know the right meeting point the
right intersection between
these two elements and this
has led me through pretty much diverse
um positions uh till now
right and the reason is being the
managing director of
8200 impact
acceleration program right but before we
get to the 8200 impact program i
have to talk a little bit about this
this dissonance between the public and
private sector so
you're you're telling me that you the
way that you're the way that you grew up
you're always looking for ways to make
an impact right
it's always been how can i unif how can
i find a connection between what i want
to do and what i can do make that impact
you become a lawyer and you go into the
public and ngo sector
and trying to affect change in your
community so tell me a little bit about
this motivation to affect change
and sort of your realization and
transition from
the public to the private sector
so i think he started doing my
internship and i did
my legal internship in one of the
biggest law firms here in tel aviv
and it was really you know high quality
practice there but i didn't really
feel connected to the mission and it was
you know defending and and providing
legal services to really big
corporations
you know big private market entities
and i i couldn't feel how we're changing
the world
by you know providing them with legal
services
and there was even a specific case where
you know i
understood the legal case it was pretty
much
obvious what should be you know the
money that should be paid
to um to the other partner um
of of the uh of the site that we
represented
um and and yet we had to spend
months and months in in district quote
in the north
you know fighting over a very pretty
much small amount of money and i said
okay this is not my
destiny uh and so i was fortunate enough
after um finishing my internship and
getting my
uh lawyer license uh to be
a legislative aide at the knesset and
and i was like
you know big fortune to to work with
former mk daliatic in her last term
after she concluded her position as the
speaker of the knesset and was the head
of the
kadima faction and even though it was
quite a short period of time um
i learned a lot and and you know working
at the knesset
amending or proposing bills to amend the
law
uh using my um knowledge as
as a tourist to pursue
social changes i really liked it right
and so
after the elections back in 2013 i
started
to work at the israeli medical
association as their
public policy director this is where i
had the chance
to promote public health issues
and represent the physicians at the
classic committees
and this is
you know except of the the vast
experience that you gain
working with um
leaders of the physician world
and working with mks with the government
um you also have the opportunities
uh to promote things that you believe in
and that that was
the right place for me back then but uh
at some point when i returned from the
humphrey fellowship i was a fulbrighter
uh in the u.s spent almost a year in
richmond virginia
uh focusing on public health management
um i came back i started being the ceo
of the non-profit in the healthcare
system
i managed to include a very important
medicine
preventive medicine in the basic health
basket here at israel it's called prep
projects polyprophylaxis that prevents
hiv transmission
but i also realized at the time
that there's something broken in the
system
it takes so much time you have to pull
so many strengths
and i think you know coffee 19 pandemic
now
has actually highlighted what i started
to realize
and feel even before the pandemic
started
and that there has to be some kind of a
game changer
in this world so we have a more balanced
economy
more opportunities for you know diverse
populations
this is where i started to
aim at working in the private sector
um okay you know and we
specifically uh to pursue change
so what in you know just a few sentences
what is that
how do you summarize that realization
that of the
of the impact that you're able to make
in the private sector versus the public
sector because i hear a lot of people
that go from the private sector to the
public sector to effect change because
they're saying
the real power lies in the decision
makers in the government and the ngos
etc
not in the private sector yet you're and
you're saying there i want to make
the biggest impact i can so i'm actually
transitioning from my work in the public
to the private am i am i getting that
right
yes you are well well the thing is that
i think the role of the government the
role of the state
actually um varies from
one situation to another and
you know something the the only thing
the government needs to do is not to
intervene
sometimes it can be the catalyst for
helping other organizations to make the
change
they can be a partner sometimes they can
be
the regulator but i think and i mean i i
truly believe that the pandemic
has highlight highlighted um this notion
they're not as strong as we as i used to
think they are
you know okay the the regulators
so you know the balance and their roles
is shifting and i don't think you know
we can ignore them absolutely not
um but i mean look at everything nobody
could have done it better than the
private market
in collaboration and cooperation with
governments
um that should be implemented other
fields too
no that makes perfect sense so given
that realization and given that
understanding and your motivation talk
to me a little bit about
what what you're spending so much of
your time now making an impact
through the 8200 impact project
what is it what are you what is the
vision and what's actually happening
today
right so we're actually affiliated with
the 80
200 alumni association and as part of
our goal to harness
human the human capital of the illuminae
of the unit for the sake of the economy
and society
we've created several acceleration
programs i run
the 8200 impact acceleration program
which supports the technological
ventures or
what we call now impacted startups
impacted startups are different
by three criteria points of
categories the first one is the
intentionality test
is whether they have initiated the whole
venture
startup company in order to make
significant change
um and to solve significant social or
environmental problem
the second how do you measure that how
do you how do you measure
intentionality amongst you know early
stage founders that are just now
beginning their journey
that's that's a wonderful question
usually by their statement
usually by the way they stick to their
intention
throughout the process even though it is
harder to be an impacted entrepreneur
it is harder to find a business model it
is harder to find investments
in many cases your beneficiaries are not
your clients because your beneficiaries
are
coming from disadvantaged communities
that cannot afford paying for your
product
and and it and then it becomes more
complicated
if they stick to their intention if they
talk about what they do
in terms of not just making profit which
is great and they have to make profit of
course
especially you know those who are um
aiming at being a startup company
but they're talking about measuring the
social impact
and it has to be embedded within the
product
then the freeze test um
you know they're doing okay with the
first test of intentionality
um right clear cut i mean still black
and white
sometimes people are doing this social
abortion um just you know stating
they care about impact about about
society or environment but you know at
the bottom line they're not
so um it does protest along along the
way
right now i said okay so that's the
first test and walk me through some of
the other criteria of how you're
of how you're observing these
entrepreneurs so the second one is
whether they intend and and
they have the ability to measure it um
we're looking at the social or
environmental
impact usually at this stage we use the
sdg the sustainable development goals of
the u.n
and it's not a perfect method
but so far you know things are happening
uh in
in this field so we're using the sdgs
mostly and the third one is you know the
financial revenue
whether they can be
[Music]
a good fit for mainstream vcs also
impact this is angelo but whether they
can
come up with a really good idea and then
product
the people we want to invest in um right
and
combination of the three criteria is
pretty much complicated
and how so how so that when you do
accept people into this cohort or into
this
group and program what actually happens
how do you actually help
these impact entrepreneurs that you now
call them
progress into their you know and make it
actually happen
yeah so it's a five month program we
usually select each year
uh between 10 to 12 um
entrepreneurs or ventures some of them
are only
cooperated as a company some some are
not
at that stage we provide them with
a weekly day of workshops and lectures
a very intensive mentorship program they
have
lead mentors professional mentors office
hours
and virtual board meetings
we you know kind of
tello made um a specific
like services plan for each entrepreneur
depending on the stage
they're at depending on their current
needs
uh and and i have to make sure
that i create for them the right space
to do amazing things
right including connect and you know
materials
support uh sometimes even credits from
you know big corporations that can help
them um
do what they do in a much faster
pace
and at the end we have a really big
event
showcase events our annual demo day
in which they're being exposed uh or
you know investors are being exposed to
to our
portfolio companies right so
so tell me a little bit about the impact
that 8200 impact is making and how do
you measure that impact are you
are you a shareholder or stakeholder in
these companies
what is sort of the relationship that
you have with the entrepreneurs that are
coming
yes so so our model is a philanthropic
one
uh we don't charge anything we don't
invest
i mean we don't get any equity
we do have a board of partners who are
actually our sponsors
and they actually you know create the
budget
that we work with um
the way we measure ourselves that's a
really good question you know
um the program is now
we're nearing the end of the sixth batch
so far
um in a survey that we conducted very
much recently
um we have the figures of the
accumulated
investment uh sum of money of our
companies
is a little bit more than 45 million
dollars
and and our startups have created more
than 100
um jobs in israel but not only in israel
which is pretty much a common criteria
to to measure
an acceleration program we also
we also ask them about whether they
measure their social impact
and then see you know accordingly if we
can also present
any progress with with specific sdgs
um right it's not that easy for uh you
know
an early stage startup uh but we do see
some progress in relating to sdgs
we're also adopting um other
methods of management within the startup
company of
you know diversity and and accessibility
for people with disability
and other criteria that are more common
in impact no
i think that makes perfect sense so i'd
love to spend the last few minutes that
we have talking a little bit more
broadly about
impact and and some lessons that you can
provide to you know young entrepreneurs
whether they're in
tel aviv can take part in or in israel
and can take part in
and this great program or or outside
around the world
what are some of the lessons that you've
learned along the way of that make up a
successful
impact venture or or at least a
successful enough to be able to take
roots
and grow even you know past the first
milestone of
of the formation of it
wonderful question well first being an
impact tech
entrepreneur is um well
it starts with being an entrepreneur and
here i have no news you have to learn
the whole you know the whole system
uh maybe people can read your book uh
that was
recently public um it it starts with
you know the notion that you want to be
an entrepreneur you're courage enough
really sometimes maybe people say you're
crazy enough to start this amazing
right very very right journey
so to be very much passionate about it
right second one that you have to know
that
making a positive impact
is not something that talk that has to
do only with
being a purpose-driven entrepreneur
it is a whole system where you also have
to measure it
right the third thing i would say
um well in many cases
our entrepreneurs that we support
have a very strong connection
between the product and their personal
life
now interesting sometimes a
really interesting advantage sometimes
it could be
very challenging so for example
a female entrepreneur that
at some point had a very negative
experience
whether in terms of domestic violence or
be or
feeling unsafe in bases but she comes up
with a brilliant idea
of creating uh right you know
that that i don't know enhances um the
the feeling of being safe on the streets
that could be an advantage i think that
can really strengthen your
your passion along the way but you have
to
realize that first it's not enough and
and
you have to be very much conscious of
not
getting in love too much with your idea
especially with your solution because
sometimes
i think that that's um yeah i think
that's a that's a wonderful point that
you're making we actually had a really
brilliant guest and i think she's
episode 190 something anita
kumri and she founded the happiness
factor and she founded it
as a result of a very abusive
relationship that she had coming from
india
into a pr into a a marriage that was
unsuccessful a very abusive
marriage and she founded an organization
to help
women gain confidence and support for
dealing with these things and
so as i i definitely see the value and
being very connected to the product
on an emotional level especially when
you're talking about impact the other
thing that i that i want to
to reiterate is is you're mentioning of
both being intentional but having but
being measurable
that you know just because you're making
a social impact and you're doing social
good often with impact
it doesn't mean that you should should
allow yourself to not measure your
process and measure
whether you're able to continue making
that impact just like any regular
venture where you have to you know you
can sometimes measure sales
measure your your revenue or your burn
rate
here maybe you don't need to measure
sales but you do want to measure
whether the impact you're making is
growing because that is the equivalent
of sales for regular adventure
but you actually want to measure both
and that's what makes it more
complicated
because you want to measure your sales
you want to to show
traction you want to show that you're
moving the needle in terms of
a specific social challenge right
wow that that makes a lot of sense i
want to
thank you for being so generous with
your time and there's more that i
that i wanted to talk about but we don't
have enough time for that
so we'll have to do another episode in
the future but before we leave i have to
ask you for the most important question
which is
three words that you would use to
describe yourself
it's the hardest question um
i would say passionate you know i can't
work with passionate people
unless i'm passionate myself about what
i do
i hope i'm genuine um
enough and and and then
other two words um maybe three phrases
not three words social activists i i
truly believe even
being now in you know in this
intersection of
business and and making an impact
i i truly believe that we're doing
social activism
uh in in innovative ways
[Music]
i love it thank you
very very much and this is wonderful
continue making a positive impact and
continue helping others make a positive
impact
and and i can't wait to share this with
the world thank you very much
thank you michelle